na ich werde Paulinen auch nicht in
Therapeuten empfehlen vorausgesetzt es
ist wirklich authentisch und nicht aus
ein Clip aus der heute show was da
wunderbar reinpassen würde aber es tut
mir leid die machen solche Witze aber
nicht doch
authentisch also es ist immer peinlich
wenn alte Männer oder alte Frauen über
junge Menschen lästern und ich habe ja
auch ein ordentlichen
nein nein alter Männer am Anfang ich
habe auch ein ordentlichen
demonstrationshintergrund aber uns haben
damals Demonstrationen noch Spaß gemacht
das sind alles kranke Menschen deswegen
haben sie vollkommen Recht entschuldigen
Sie dass ich einen zustimme das ist
pathologische Phänomen sind das sind
paranoika und Hysteriker in einer
paranoiden und hysterischen Gesellschaft
der Staat hat jetzt Manifest versagt es
sind Straftatbestände denen wir es zu
tun haben